doubt I'd see it but I you know there
used to be a little bit of tear on the
side of a party well yeah I was playing
with tira I mean I've seen him you sung
Meena before there's a lot of characters
that couldn't come out so we shall see
who he brings up to the stage
yeah but and I mean I I can't imagine
seeing any other character from drapion
other than nightmare
yeah sure we're gonna see you the good
old night terror all right all right the
question is of course is whose party
Wolf's gonna pick so I think for the
most like you mentioned he's mostly
associated with Killick right recently
he's been playing a lot more Cassandra I
feel like the newest character of course
I believe yeah is the newest chair here
he ain't available in Sylacauga 6 so far
so all right I he's so happy
trait the artist is so calm and
collected like you they had they
finished matches earlier they're like is
that over is it done
should I set up now that's definitely
not do you hood yeah again we talked
about his killing context you accents
the halcyon days of gold so calories
right like it's it's just been around
this whole kind of everybody know
starting a card pretty much
and I'd say that uh not a bad overall
pick still very strong character he's
doing his best
I would say Keith Lucas doing his best
and we're gonna get into our first match
that believe unless this is a bust check
it looks like it might be Dan just only
do but check perverse carry once against
terror charges I mean it's very aptly
named right Tarot to see the ton of
damage on flock with those things one of
the things that is if he's gonna be able
to represent GI on our gif straight yeah
it's scary it's like if you you're going
up against what you know is gonna be a
very very strong pressure move whether
it's a block or on hit and you have to
just get the timing right you have to be
able to get them to the right range of
the right timing it looks like actually
he is gonna be picking killing into the
matchup we're going right into it guys
so this is party wolf versus drapion
first match one of the interactions I'm
kind of looking out for is a lot of the
time one of the scariest ranges to be at
is nightmare six be arranged
all right but Kulick is one of the
characters who just has range he's able
to fight around that area he's able out
pokum at least from Bad rape so it'll be
just to see how that's gonna play out
but I think this is gonna be mostly
Andres out for finding a way to get in
or start his offense for the most part
you know release on paper a lot of the
quicker moves and that Bennett goes to
killing here you go first game right now
first game at Psalm 16 in fact on the
winter side right here party wolf
drapion this is important so if they win
here they're gonna be a good position to
be able to qualify later would you play
out of course our top eight all right
going right into nice talk under that
and we'll kind of mix up are we gonna
see ok went for the mid right there the
aging is gonna be able to hit and of
course testing a living where there's
great things with a g8 recover so
quickly but also covers great ground
official people to step
yeah and I'm block its 0 for nightmare
plus 2 for sick freak but you know
mix-up that's after this is really
important though because one could be
death whatever the 6k though that's I
there's one low and then all its time
able to squeak out that win there in the
first route so party wolf that's six P
we were talking about gotta see the
interactions based on that that GI is
gonna be able to be hit afterwards yeah
that's the thing too it's a bit scary
you would think the you know players
like party won't be able to kind of
scope that out on it out grim strident
good amount of damage forcing this whole
charge at a podium wolf so you're gonna
see that health terrain right now but I
mean the damage output that's possible
from keel ik here insane right insane
right now he's gonna get a nice combo
here and it's gonna put treat not in a
very bad position because if he lands is
critically it could be all over he's
gonna have to be very very careful but
the six be with the terrorist heart that
does you know a sea of it itself yeah
it's like a mini mini bomb follow up
here it's trying to chop away here try
to create space with that low kick just
outside of the raged perfect punish
there from party wolf okay just a little
bit too far for the graph to be able to
connect on that one supposed to be a be
that was supposed to be a gar a be a
yeah hit the but it's too close together
accidentally got the reversal I mean who
knows maybe he was tried to get a hard
read there but either way not a good
time to do it now I'm almost certain
that that at that reverse legends for
behavior it's really unfortunate in
scenario right there from great the
onion party both though capitalizing
beautifully forcing drinking on to try
and push his advantage at the round
start with immediate soltahr do it yeah
even Eve you try to follow up it was
just the right hit at the right time
party woman's taking that quite
convincingly just showing just the
superior spacing no wait what he's gonna
swing against nightmare and he just he
made a count he made a count that was
incredibly patient
party wolf he was able to catch the
rhythm the drapion was running and he
got him so many different counter hits
tons right there is just there's Connor
he thought after Connor hand son
and then eventually you know there was a
couple here there but I feel like a lot
of the damage was just kind of like
getting him but when when he felt like
dray Theon was gonna press but yeah kind
of just out spaced him there at
especially the last two major hits when
he got those both of those leaflets
obviously had had a bit of trouble with
this earlier but he knew exactly when to
step in a straight an opening from self
okay stage change right here for Tracy
it's a lot smaller definitely consider
to be one of the more volatile stages of
the game that's of course gonna be these
players being said they're gonna
obviously go for the wall the ring out I
should say though the ring out advantage
okay back escape on that one trying to
put him closer to the ledge but party
wolf was privy
Oh up here and look at that oh he
doesn't get it off axis I believe that's
the fourth David yeah you'll notice that
on Tracy on has not been able to feel
safe enough to go for a lot of the
revenge attacks yeah I mean we've seen a
few with the out with the case but not
really things like 6b or anything like
that that's kind of his game here right
now party wolf doing a great job with
the positioning in the stage oh wow you
went for a big are depicting something
out the trade on the throw ventually
going to be able to get the lethal hit
because of that good damage but the oaky
situation is important just backs
alright time to use it as well too he
doesn't want to use it too late oh he
had hit ready because he hits with so
many of those prior to that got the
lethal hit got the round and now he's
currently on set point just like that
one round away
atheon really needs this now he's gonna
have a metre and a little bit we'll see
if he's able to utilize it in any way to
help him take that rounded better yeah
that's been breathing hard for him to
even move around the damn screen party
wolf has been catching it at every Adams
Avenue so many horizontals to be able to
catch Stephane there's an AGA though
caught him with the stun he's gonna get
a territory finally
let's see what are you like oh man and
that we've punished their what for a
grab just outside of range I wonder if
that wasn't it's always hard to tell
whether or not it's a grabber in a gar
it is party wolf going to be taking it
over trade on clean rounds there's April
to close it up three straight rounds but
of course he's gonna be moving on into
our topic
winners side and we're gonna see him
later on today drink there now going to
the very very tough losers bracket with
yeah yeah any players
oh he has another shot at it though it's
not like it's it's over that's the
beauty of double elimination right but
it is the LCQ this is one of the most
stacked bracket that scholars has seen
thus far just in general so it's every
Matt this entire thing is a bloodbath
this is like they get out of this LCQ
congratulations you got to play against
these monsters next yeah it's gonna be
tough either way but I want to see that
player do well I mean after you you go
through the odds of just you know some
of the best players for that obviously
didn't qualify already but some of the
best players here you gotta have that
confidence right you have to have that
confidence I think not just the
confidence but whomever is able to be
able to take this entire LCQ absolutely
has a great shot at being able to fight
anyone in that oh yeah in those
invitational spots in my opinion just
because not only just like the the the
nature of this of the of the how strong
this LCQ is right not like the the bevy
of strong players but also because
because going into it they're gonna they
know exactly who they could be fighting
yeah and that's the advantage and you
know that is I feel like the
disadvantage for the players that are
already qualified is they don't know
who's gonna be coming in they do have
obviously the the benefit of watching
now but they better be paying it's a
it's a better guy that has to be paying
attention the most right because I
believe that he's God is the one who has
to face the Aussie correct at least face